hommage aux blindes test
j'accueille didier bébête
goody et baissent donc tout l'été sur
france 2 samantha du scan est clair qu
est ce qu il a les chefs sont des hommes
mais non pierre mas des petits détails
va bien marcher sur france 2 mais
écoutez on est assez content je ne peux
pas parler que madrid voit sa masse est
contente ya un dvd qui s'appelle oups
samantha oups
voilà voilà on est derrière oui je sais
pas si vous avez regardé le dvd et il ya
des chiens petit clin d'oeil pour vous
parce que c'est vrai c'est mignon
bon ça vous êtes là tu vois je t'avais
dit faire bien a ajouté le seul
d'ailleurs sur l'émission comment donc
je te prête pour le blind test tout à
fait thierry bien eh bien on va
accueillir dj benji des arabes
bonsoir
votre album s'appelle les visages se
meurt 2005
on l'entendra d'ailleurs un extrait
pendant le générique de fin
richy que des pierres s'ils saluent
alors vous connaissez le principe d'un
test au début c'est le par équipes c'est
l'équipe de pierre palmade contre
l'équipe ii à lambres christophe lambert
et puis après ce sera le chacun pour sa
gueule évidemment alors on y va
je salue le nom de l'interprète
évidemment pas le nom du morceau à les
usines ont voté pour
que ça leur donne
c'est dans
avant
certains points pour l'équipe de
christophe lambert qu on continue
benzi
oui
j'avais deux points pour l'équipe de
christophe lambert numéro 3 e
attention non mais là c'est pour leur
numéro quatre bras
alors allez y
les
manger
les dijonnais
delage
en guadeloupe
pathétique
colin bravo
voilà
on continue dur dur dur allons-y
sa note au top au berry non d'assez rare
amérique
mais bon
oui oui
il est avec nous à la marche ici
maintenant yar'adua christ
alors allons-y continue j'adore ce point
non
m
nous on a combien trois soirs olala
c'est très chaud le numéro 7 de valeo
alors
enfin si nul au parma bentley mulsanne
et bravo
quel
des panneaux
très bien on continue donc ça fait
combien les skis 4 4 on s'est serré
comme ça non
on continue
bah oui ma machine
mais
ouais
très laid en continu
oh
capa
c'est
et sa fille d'oussama
non
l'espèce 5,6 et chaussées sur wasikowska
et voilà donc on parle si bien vraiment
une égalité au parking donc je propose
qu'on ne passe pas au chacun pour sa
gueule qu'on reste dans le par équipe
parce qu'il reste deux morceaux et
finalement c'est la seule façon de
départager ces deux équipes en combat 2d
trop sais pas si vous voulez bien ma
chère amie on passe au banco
non je l'avais sur la bouteille c'est
bon là voilà c'est l'équipe-type de
chair qui marque un point
il recensera ludivine jeudi à et
maintenant le super banco mesdames
messieurs très très très très dur très
très très dur et c'est bien
l'homme leur ligne
randonnées jeux
dans la région jeu
non
m
je
chaque
ok
et voilà on applique donc je vais
expliquer le score basse et 8,6 et c'est
laurent baffie qui a encore gagné
voilà c'était la première de tout le
monde en parle
je suis crevé je suis en lice en partie
en vacances mais j'espère
j'espère que vous êtes voilà ça vise à
intéresser valin et là déjà